[Music]
it was this beautiful woman just
literally tripped and fell into my life
I spun into her life it's official Megan
Marco has decided who will walk her down
the aisle to marry Prince Harry on
Friday Kensington Palace announced
Harry's father Prince Charles will have
the honor of escorting the bride to be
quote Miss Megan Markel has asked his
Royal Highness the Prince of Wales to
accompany her down the aisle of the
choir of st. George's Chapel on her
wedding day
adding the Prince of Wales is pleased to
be able to welcome miss Marcal to the
royal family in this way I mean frankly
this is not how we usually do royal
weddings
this comes after Markel shared her
father thomas would sadly not be
attending the royal wedding due to his
help a report surfaced that Thomas was
scheduled for a surgery following a
heart attack I was told by sources close
to Megan last night that she was utterly
heartbroken that she couldn't believe
that this was happening just days before
her wedding things have certainly turned
around for the better and we can't wait
to watch Megan and Harry say I do on May
19
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]